all right so yellow jackets episode four
man they they keep ramping things up big
reveals weird self-aware flashbacks and
even more Moss but welcome back to heavy
spoilers you're home for well uh heavy
heavy spoilers and in this video we're
going to be discussing everything in
episode 4 full on spoilers callbacks and
even more outlandish theories turn on
some player because Javi come back you
can blame it all on Natalie anyway if
you enjoyed this video hitting that like
button is much appreciated and subscribe
to heavy spoilers to stay up to date on
all of our Yellow Jackets coverage with
all of that out of the way thank you so
much for clicking this I'm your host
Jared now let's get into Yellowjackets
episode four all right jumping right
into the biggest shocker of this episode
Javi is alive who what how why I mean we
all kind of assumed he was out there
somehow living off the land but like wow
aside from him looking like he's aged
Travis is Happy Lottie is confused
Natalie dumbfounded and Javi is just
oblivious to everything Tyson van are
the two that actually found him running
around the Frozen Forest which all seems
a bit coincidental but then again van
says this
see what's right in front of you maybe
we too are diving too deep but the
opening of this episode is Van
essentially using the Dual Persona of
ties to track down and map out all of
the symbols marked on the trees which
she seems fairly successful with because
whatever is driving taisa is leading her
exactly to these trees again it could be
the no eyes man who we still don't have
any concrete answers about upon each new
symbol discovered van channels her inner
Charlie Kelly and basically Pepe
Sylvia's the symbols onto the already
created map from episode 1 and is
convinced that all of these symbols
actually make out a larger symbol
covering a majority of the forest but
one area of the map is still missing a
symbol and Van is convinced that a
symbol will be found in that area but
instead of a symbol this is where taisa
and Van find Javi who I'm pretty sure is
the one who is stealing the meat from
the shed that Shawna was upset about at
the start of this episode but another
weird thing is that the two find another
tree stump that is melted snow around it
and moss on it hashtag Mass gate baby
last week we theorized that this
constant discovery of melted snow and
now with Javi being alive means that
there may be some sort of underground
Springs mining tunnels something Beneath
The Cabin in the forest that allowed for
Javi to survive this long from the
elements maybe lottie's visions of a
hatch and tunnels are in fact true
because van and taisa aren't the only
ones to pull some Voodoo Forest magic
because with Lottie saying Javi was
still alive back in episode 1 the group
is now viewing both Lottie and taisa as
these pun intended Visionaries plus they
think Lottie was the one responsible for
the bird offering from last week as we
can see Travis eating some bird soup
this of course sets up the Lottie versus
Natalie hunting competition at the heart
of episode with Natalie tracking down
the same white moose from last week
Frozen in a nearby lake this got me by
surprise because I'm gonna be honest I
thought the moose was more of a
hallucination of Good Fortune to Natalie
for returning Jackie's bones however
with the antlers being the only thing
Frozen above the lake this could have
been a designation that Natalie was
about to become the antler Queen but
losing the Moose to the depths of the
lake was her losing her chance to be the
leader lottie's side of the hunting
competition is much more in the realm of
what the [__] is going on because she
essentially goes on a Vision Quest
listening to the forest and having the
mysterious symbols talk to her hell even
Lottie comes close to losing faith
[Music]
[__] me
but she stumbles upon the same weird
stump at the end of season one and it
looks similar to the way that Travis's
Visions portrayed it in episode one
candles and other trinkets decorating it
Lottie spills blood to the stump which I
think is the same dripping noise Mari
had been hearing throughout these last
couple episodes now Mari with her belief
in lottie's guidance May 2 be receiving
visions of the future or rather hearing
the future lottie's Visions hit an
all-time strange as she finds all of
these objects relating to Laura Lee the
plane her teddy bear and cross necklace
as she follows a Beat from the Lost
series climbing down a hatch that leads
into an elevator this does lend a bit
more evidence to my underground dwelling
Theory because the elevators don't look
the same here but lottie's vision is
almost that of a flashback with all of
the yellow jackets in a 90s-esque mall
together this setup is similar to The
Feast at the end of episode 2 as the
other girls poke fun at lottie's Sticky
Bandits run of stealing clothing this
feels like both a memory but also the
same plane of existence that Laura Lee
was in when Jackie saw her at the end of
season one heck this could even be the
weird in-between space Travis was trying
to get to when he accidentally hanged
himself and Lottie is slowly figuring
out how to transport here it's hella
trippy though that the yellow jackets
theme song faintly plays in the
background
foreign
it's a great little detail don't get me
wrong but I think that it has a much
deeper meaning Into the Wilderness or
just the Yellow Jacket show in general
isn't what we think it is I'll talk more
about this in the ending Theory section
but luckily Lottie is inception kicked
out of there and saved by her followers
again if we believe the Moose antlers
relate to that of whoever the antler
Queen will be Lottie sitting in the tub
mirrors how the moose was positioned in
the lake anyway vladi and Natalie make
up over a solid Predator handshake but
the bonding is cut short by javi's
return and everyone is against Natalie
because she was the one that said he was
dead and everyone thinks now that Ty and
Lottie are some sort of wilderness Gods
even though both cases are sort of dumb
luck at this point last week we
theorized that taisa was going off to
find van because of the hand across the
face in the mirror looked awfully
similar to the masks that the pair War
at the Doom's coming celebration in
season one and that is exactly correct
as it's revealed that the while you were
streaming video rental store that was in
Jessica's files belongs to van so before
the episode ends on this Cliffhanger
taisa's dream walking can can we call it
that or did Marvel Studios trademark
that whatever we see Tai in the weird
between State break into Jessica Roberts
apartment in New York whom we can assume
is no longer alive because of Misty's
poisoning from season one Jessica was
hired by taisa to keep tabs on all of
the surviving Yellow Jackets so she
grabs the information for van and
unknowingly starts a road trip from New
Jersey to New York then to Ohio which is
roughly eight to nine hour drive when
she's picked up by a trucker I honestly
thought that this was going to be a
large Marge situation where it wasn't
real or that the trucker had nefarious
motives but nope everything everything
seems all by the book however the there
is a shot that lingers heavily on an
upside down nudie pen taisa picks up off
of the truck floor with this lingering
longer than a cranberry song I thought
that there may be a deeper meaning here
but with the end reveal of Tai going off
to see van I think it's solely a fun
object that reminds her of van or even
the two had a similar pen when they were
teen Yellow Jackets like I said taisa is
dropped off at Vans or video rental
store called while you were streaming
which of course is a play on her
favorite movie or the one that she
talked about in the wilderness while you
were sleeping I don't think that this is
coincidental but rather has a connection
to taisa's sleepwalking again that movie
and Tai both deal with events happening
while one of the main characters is
asleep so I'm guessing that the next
episode we're going to be seeing things
from Van's perspective and maybe learn
more of the two's history and what led
to this decade-long Rift in present day
a couple things to note in Van's store
though are some of the move movies on
the staff picks board Mean Girls right
next to into the wild this is exactly
the way the Wilderness is turning with
the differing sides being made amongst
the girls while into the wild takes
place in the Alaskan Wilderness Alaska
Canada pretty close bound is a Forbidden
Love Story between two women Ty and Van
here the Rosemary's Baby movie poster
when she walks in ties into Shauna's
baby along with some of the maybe
Supernatural elements and lottie's weird
visions and followers hell I could even
see Lottie having something to do with
shawna's baby especially if there are
complications and lastly the It's a
Wonderful Life poster a movie about
seeing the what if scenario if you
hadn't followed a certain path in life
which I would say heavily ties in with
the coach Scott what if Visions from
last week again this could be
foreshadowing or just alluding to past
events however coach Scott does
dissociate into another flashback show
showing him and Paul again living
together as we find out that this is
Ben's first kind of serious relationship
as opposed to Paul's and its heavily
implied Ben is scared but the two see a
future together this scene seems oddly
placed in the episode but I think it's
because he's reading from his book again
of which he read last week and it's
called the Magnus it's interesting
because this novel again ties in with
Greek myths with the main character
contemplating ending his own life and
beginning to see Visions unable to tell
reality from fiction this is what I take
from coach Scott here he's dreaming of a
life that could have been and is slowly
getting closer and closer to ending his
own life again there's elements of It's
a Wonderful Life trickled in here as
well Shawna Jeff and Cali all have an
interesting Journey throughout this
episode starting with the family still
holding on to Secrets very much being
separated as individuals rather than a
close-knit family hell even and even the
framing of Jeff and Shauna here shows
that they are at odds but as this
episode plays out slowly discovering
what the others are hiding they
surprisingly are closer than they've
ever been at the end of this episode and
I think the biggest reason is that Shana
comes clean to Cali about all of her
shenanigans while allowing Kali to do
the same but more so threatening her if
she doesn't because when Shauna learned
of Cali's lying Adam's burnt license and
the bedroom protection I bet Shawna was
contemplating that very decision in a
weird dysfunctional family Dynamic this
secluded talk is exactly what Shauna and
Cali needed to bond but there are a
couple of subtle things to focus on in
this conversation obviously Shauna is
nonchalant about ending someone's life
but alludes to Jeff's blackmail
reasoning in an odd way because they
we did things out there that
we're really ashamed of almost acting
like it wasn't actually her back in the
wilderness the yellow jackets were
entirely different from who they are
today I mean I want to say that there is
far more to this stutter and glances
again they could have all been possessed
by whatever Lottie was terrified of and
in reality they had no control over
their actions either way they are one
big happy family at the end of things
but still holding on to some secrets for
themselves Shauna never talking about
how the van actually got back and Cali
has yet to disclose her secret dates
with Jay the police officer so Jay has
bound to come up in this next episode
and cause a whole new ripple effect
while I truly think Shauna wasn't
actually roping Kelly in to be
transparent but instead she was doing
this to get leverage down the road
Shauna is reverting to a Wilderness game
of chess almost Survivor
outwit outplay Outlast trying to slowly
manipulate all of these people into
positions that she can easily control on
a much lighter side of things is the
whole story thread of Misty and Walter
two weirdos on a road trip date it's
kind it's kind of cute there's a lot
more evidence as to something happening
to Misty's best friend crystal in the
wilderness because when Walter mentions
Misty is a good friend she really takes
it to heart it's pretty rare to have a
friend who's relentlessly got your back
thank you
so yeah I'm saying that she had to like
betray Crystal her best friend to
survive the winter but that stayed with
her in a form of PTSD but also the love
of musicals is front and center with
Walter having all of the classics on
cassette tape again a little sauce of
him to have all of these ready at the go
but easily explains away why he knew she
loved musicals some people pointed out
in episode 3 but there's potentially
more to Walter than meets the eye
potentially something evil when talking
last week he mentions the two blossoming
relationship
maybe I'm just a board Moriarty looking
for his Sherlock
so with Moriarty being the nefarious one
this may be the first subtle hint Walter
has something up his sleeve especially
when it's revealed later during lunch
that he's a millionaire after a
scaffolding accident I could see him
pulling some strings to actually have
this happen to him he does seem a bit
sketched too to be honest Misty plays
the song rainbow to her from the 1978
musical Evita which both ties back to
the song Misty and Crystal are singing
when they're doing chores in the cabin
and sort of refers to her relationship
with Walter in Evita Eva Peron climbed
the ladder of Fame using men to get
ahead similar to Misty using Walter here
to find her friend which is a very loose
interpretation of friend when we're
talking about Natalie the pair figure
out lottie's purple goon squad is close
selling honey at the local farmers
market under the name Sunshine honey
again a reference to Lottie being the
son for which they follow learning they
are on Route 19 somewhere now some
people people have theorized lottie's
compound is actually the same location
where the Yellow Jacket's plane crashed
in the wilderness but the distances
don't line up Route 19 in comparison to
New Jersey's roughly in Pennsylvania or
New York while the Wilderness was in the
heart of the Canadian Frontier however I
do see Lottie purposely modeling it
after the same landmarks of the
Wilderness the lake cabins tree stump
all of it the two check into a bed and
breakfast Walter using the Alias John
Wayne the old American hero but looking
back at a history that's not necessarily
the case while Misty uses the Alias lady
malawan which is a pseudonym for agathic
Christie the accomplished mystery
novelist tying in with Misty's obsession
with Detective work the Sparks angst in
my pants plays as the pair are literally
the same person marrying one another
following the same nightly routine down
to even checking behind the beds now the
song implies that both are sexually
frustrated hinting at this blossoming
into more of a potential romantic
relationship down the road but if Walter
does in fact have a darker side to him
this could go either way I mean freak
misty out or she Embraces it because she
too is far from a squeaky clean person
alright then keep your secrets Lottie
and present day has one of the biggest
question marks next to it because her
Visions are coming back after years
mentioning a couple of suspicious things
to her therapist
and it needs to stop
they need to stop
because they're not real
much like Shauna Lottie refers to her
Visions as they but I don't think she's
talking about her Visions here instead
it's whoever the evil spirits are or
whoever takes influence over them in the
wilderness of which we haven't yet seen
again they are not real something Lottie
talks about in Her speech in the opening
of this season right now there is a
version of you
that knows exactly who you really are
and what you really want it doesn't
matter right
because it isn't
these might possibly be from a different
plane of existence but still have power
in our world maybe doppelgangers of the
Wilderness crew this may explain Javi
just popping out of nowhere especially
when Lottie says her Visions became
something different these Visions
continue when Lottie sees the queen of
hearts with the eyes all crossed out
when reading through gratitude entries a
startling sight at first that could mean
a handful of things back in the
wilderness playing cards were in fact in
the cabin so the Queen of Hearts
designates who will be the antler Queen
giving them power over the others and
picking who will be sacrificed when food
is scarce or whoever has given the card
or draws the card is that week's
sacrifice which would explain the pit
girl probably Drew this card and then
was food for the other survival in an
interview with Sophie nelise who plays
teen Shauna may have given this away
actually if you were to pick that card
to get killed we'd be like no let's just
give it to someone else we can't count
come on the weird thing is in season one
Travis or Natalie mentions that there
are no queens in the deck but then again
this season two poster cleverly has the
same Queen of Hearts hidden whatever it
is causes Lottie to again make a blood
sacrifice in present day saying the
words just be enough please being used
as a way to Harbor off evil spirits
Lottie and the others only had the
illusion of escaping the evil as they've
always been with it or it's always been
following him almost like teased when
Natalie's talking here almost like she
wants to give the illusion of freedom
and all of lottie's cult is maybe an
elaborate way of keeping whatever it is
from coming after her and the original
yellow jackets because we learn in this
episode the members are to cut ties with
their family members so if anyone
disappears AKA is sacrificed their
family will probably not come looking
for them Lottie knows way more than
she's letting on and Natalie's stealing
the keys is going to find something big
in the locked closet next week maybe
even the death records of previous
members and blows this whole thing out
of the water when Misty shows up but
then again Natalie surprisingly seems to
be fitting in very out of character from
the beginning of this season but she's
wearing a little bit more purple here or
there opening up and her and Lisa's
relationship is growing and I think it's
solely because Lisa's home life reminds
Natalie of her own when she was a teen
it's nice to see the pair really helping
one another with Natalie saving her fish
her goldfish the 14th Gilly and Natalie
pushing away the shot to show that she
is now sober at Lisa's mothers it looks
like she may be moving though there's uh
moving boxes all over the house so maybe
lottie's cult is going to be the only
family that Lisa has moving forward but
also the little red umbrella on all of
the boxes could be a reference to the
2010 novel The Red Umbrella which starts
with a teen girl wanting independence
from her overbearing mother and seeks
his Independence against her mother's
wishes a bit of a stretch maybe a little
the only other thing of note is Aquila
finding the mouse and keeping it as a
pet this is food I mean they're starving
and she's probably going to feed this
thing to keep it alive so I could see
these kind of falling as Wilderness
violations if you will and down the road
she'll be on the chopping block so uh
we'll see but before we wrap up I wanted
to touch on a couple of theories
theories theories it's Theory time
I'm still sticking by the mine shaft
underground tunnels abandoned mining
operation Theory we touched on last week
I mean where else was Javi hiding this
whole time to escape the elements and
survive and we even see Lottie in a
weird dream state go down a hatch into a
tunnel similar to the ones in her
Visions from season one it could even be
a whole Cabin in the Woods situation
where they are being watched by someone
else all of this caused the plane to go
down would explain Javi being released
back to the group and the weird static
transitions between some scenes makes me
feel like somebody's watching TV like
all of this is a television program like
think uh the the The Truman Show the
second one is that there is an
underworld like uh like a mere World
some sort of Supernatural plane of
existence where different versions of
everyone exist think like a parallel
universe or Multiverse Theory because
the mysterious symbol does look like
someone is being lowered through the
ground into somewhere else and there are
tons of references to doubles or
mirrored images in this episode Shauna
and Jeff in the kitchen Shauna mirrored
in Cali's room Misty and Walter's whole
bed and breakfast Montage taisa dream
walking with her double the queen of
hearts card the pen being flipped upside
down and a few other things I I probably
missed it's a duality of Two Worlds and
lottie's ritual didn't actually find
Javi but rather reached into that other
world and pulled that Hobby in this is
why he's hella confused when he gets
back to the cabin the symbol could be a
marker to do this because it's also
drawn on Simone's hand because taisa
didn't know if she would survive or not
and the what if scenario of Coach Scott
from last episode is actually his life
in that other world throwing that It's a
Wonderful Life post a reference into the
mix Maybe maybe not anyway that has been
this week's theories Theory time none of
this is real remember what Lottie said
anyway that is episode 4 of season two
at this point I have no idea what to
think right when I think I have
something figured out there's a splinter
into even more potential Supernatural
Wilderness evils and questions that I
need answers to like does van have a
secret to tice's Second Persona how the
heck did Javi survive and where along
with lottie's rituals in present day the
one thing I am convinced of is that
there is some sort of underground bunker
mine other mere underworld that I hope
we find out more about sooner rather
than later but let us know your best
theories or ideas or just thoughts on
this episode of what the heck is going
on also this episode we got a little bit
earlier with some unfinished VFX so if
anything is drastically different please
let us know and I'll let you know we're
currently running a competition giving
away three copies of the Superman
collection on the 15th of April and all
you got to do to get a chance of winning
this is like this video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below on your thoughts of Yellowjackets
episode 4. we pick the comments at
random at the end of every single month
and the winners of last month are on
screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos right over there we're cranking
them out folks you keep watching we keep
making but with all of that out of the
way thank you so much for your constant
support I've been Jared I'll see you in
the next one take care and peace